while it's still the early days of via
we are starting to see some fabulous
demos and really promising future titles
since we're sponsored by Samsung gear VR
today I thought we'd take a look at five
of the most promising and exciting we
are supported titles a lot of VR
headsets are looking pretty unwieldy at
this stage but once you're out in space
in your very own ship chances are you'll
start noticing that a Valkyrie has been
one of the game's leading the charge to
prove that VR can be more than a dumb
gimmick the intergalactic space
dogfighting game takes place within the
pre-established world of EVE Online a
game more often populated by hotshot
economists than ace pilots the game will
be playable on PlayStation VR and will
launch with the oculus rift if your VR
cravings stem from wanting to fly around
space and to take on foes while fully
immersed in the game world
this one is promising to deliver just
that while Crytek games have been hit or
miss in the past their game worlds are
generally consistently gorgeous so
getting to explore one in VI is pretty
damn tempting Robinson the journey will
be making use of the CryEngine to treat
us to will surely be one of the
best-looking we are experiences out next
year not to mention that the game
utilizes a prehistoric setting filled
with awesome natural sights and plenty
of dinosaurs you'll play as a young boy
who's landed on a mysterious planet and
begins to venture about Crytek is also
hinted they're looking to incorporate
haptic gloves and other similar
accessories into the game fortunately
since t play is a little kid one of
those haptic sensations is unlikely to
be you getting job done by a dinosaur
earlier this year PlayStation showed off
their demo for VR team shooter rigs a
mechanized combat league
the virtual reality Edition actually
kind of makes sense in the context of
this colorful shooter since its mech
based so you'll be getting into some
kind of gear either way the first-person
sporty shooter looks fast-paced and
frantic and if anything it'll be
fascinating to see how a fast-moving
multiplayer game that requires precision
holds up in virtual reality controlling
your mech involves you aiming and
shifting the direction of your suit by
looking in that direction so we'll have
to see how those prone to motion
sickness are going to handle this one
insomniac games the creators of Ratchet
and Clank and sunset overdrive appear to
be trying their hand at creating a
third-person adventure game for the
oculus rift called edge of nowhere
mechanically this game will let you move
the camera with your head while
presumably using traditional controls
like many of the VR offerings we're
seeing crop up this one also wants to
scare the pants off you the narrative
centers around Victor an unlucky bloke
who stuck scaling the wintery wilderness
of Antarctica and faces off against the
environment some fearsome beasts days
and the terrors of his hallucinations
now for this last game I have cheated a
little since it's actually officially
out and so we know a lot about it that's
that it is fantastic and well worth your
time I have to commend keep talking and
nobody explodes for doing something
completely off the wall and different
keep talking is a two-player game where
one player consults a very dense twenty
odd page manual to help disarm a
randomized bomb that the other player is
looking at in virtual reality well this
is also a fantastic game without the
attentions of certainly higher when one
player is in VR feels completely trapped
with the bomb and doesn't really want to
get or virtually exploded keep talking
and nobody explodes may be smaller in
scale than other VR titles but it is
extremely fun and will surely make or
break your friendships by testing your
communication skills let me know down in
that comment section what the are
experience your mystic
for right now and I will catch you again
next week